hey i was just gonna report somebody on  the freeway was walking in the middle of  the freeway and pulled a gun on somebody  but i see an officer right here i'm  gonna stop and talk to the officer yes  um exit six south there's a man with a  gun shooting i fifteen six i'll fix it  okay okay let me get you over to highway  okay just in the lane hi yes i'm i'm on  i-15 northbound and there's the guys  again yes did they actually take the car  i don't know if they took the car but we  saw the gun oh they got out of the car  he's still going  hyundai tomorrow silver  is gonna go southbound  [Music]  um  [Music]  except  show me your hat  [Music]  shots fired shots fired  [Music]  barnes street  she's about to hit  500  he's bailing out he's battling out  [Music]  negative we're on orange street  and  100 south he's going through  the railroad tracks  hey  [Music]  [Applause]  all right 100  [Music]  no he's going to pass